se você está enfrentando problemas como
caspa ou cabelos secos os aços grasses
especiais do Óleo de coco são perfeitos
para melhorar a saúde capilar você pode
utilizá-lo como condicionador natural
assim como uma máscara hidratante e se
você quer cabelos longos e saudáveis o
óleo de coco pode te ajudar porque ele
previne danos causados por produtos
químicos fortalece o cabelo evitando
quebra e pontas duplas que atrapalha o
crescimento Agora se a caspa é um
incômodo na sua vida Experimente
utilizar uma colher de sopa de óleo de
coco massageando o couro cabeludo por 3
minutos depois espere 30 minutos para
lavar a cabeça com o uso contínuo você
vai notar a diferença na caspa